the spaceship rocket ignites sending the
craft up into space a little over mach
3. it goes from indigo to midnight to
dark blue to seeing a curvature to
holy sh
and then
i want that moment
hey
i am bert chrysler and i am definitely
going to spend all gq's money
[Music]
first category i'm excited shirts let's
take a look at some shirts qy
men's deep v-neck
16.99
flexible soft and comfortable all things
i like
perfect for running crossfit and
strength worthy workouts not when i wear
shirts
and a hundred percent cotton all right
next one fendi black silk
organza shirt fifteen hundred dollars
arms and the neck are polyester the body
of the shirt is silk half sleeve semi
sheer silk in black vented synar seams
not sure i even need those
i actually i'm not even joking i thought
about wearing this for my netflix
special because i wanted to go razzle
dazzle i wanted to go
leather pants like some some real
diamonds cowboy boots like really doing
and i thought shirtless is my thing i'll
go with this
but it's so distracting
oddly enough this shirt is more
distracting than being shirtless
exposed nipple shirt 20
this shirt simulates exposed nipples i
sold shirts like this i sold shirts that
had my my chest
and it said body shots world tour
those shirts are now in uh east africa
uh we donated them because
they sold so little spider web glow in
the dark cover nipple covers that's not
it's not bad
it's the nipple that people are offended
by right glows in the dark which is
important hypoallergenic
medical grade adhesive that will last
all day
long
i'm definitely going with the black silk
organza shirt fifteen hundred and ninety
dollars it's a steal and i bet it would
look a little different on me i'm not
gonna lie to you i'm actually i'm
actually might buy that for real and
just test it out on one show
[Music]
cars rolls-royce wraith cryptos
starting at 400 000
limited edition only 50 made oh i like
that you're selling me on that if i know
that when i see the other one on the
street i get the high five i'm like
what's up like doing comics pass on an
airport i like that fuel consumption
don't care horsepower don't care it's a
rolls royce don't care don't care don't
care does it have leather seats can i
pull a umbrella out of the side that's
all that matters to me i like a good
big-bodied sedan old man car turn on
some steely dan light a cigar crack the
window it's your car for four hundred
thousand dollars you do what you want in
your car i'm into this car lamborghini
moroccan evo rwd spider
288 thousand dollars with 411 for taxes
i'm sure
design is based on the silky hexagonal
form
of the carbon atom
a lamborghini speaks more to my
generation than any other car because
that was the sexy car the sexy one we
did on the internet back then that we
saw on cannonball run the lamborghini
showed up and you're like what's that
the [ __ ] doors flip up like what are
we
i mean that's like that's like watching
someone take their pants off over their
head
the tesla x plaid edition
it goes zero to 60 in in negative three
seconds but it's still a tesla it's not
like it's not a car it's a it's a form
of transportation i want my car
to go
like i don't wanna i don't wanna be
looking around for a plug the way i feel
with my phone when it's dying and be
like i gotta charge my car i'm on two
percent does anyone have a plug i love
that he made being environmentalists
sexy that's so cool
but i also
i want people to look at my car and go
do you need that oh shut the [ __ ] up
a ford mustang
155 thousand dollars 1967
gt500 clone blueprint engine 324 347
with the novi supercharger i don't know
if they have this anywhere else in the
world and if you're in other parts of
the world leave a comment in the comment
sections
in america our parents cars smelled like
cars they smelled like a little bit of
diesel a little bit of foot and some
mcdonald's it smelled like a car the
only problem is you get into a car
accident the steering wheel goes through
your chest it's the only problem with
this car i'm gonna make a decision based
on vanity i'm losing my hair i know you
can't tell too bad but it's like
thinning right i have thin hair if i buy
the lamborghini then i'm that guy okay
i'm the guy
with the small dick thinning hair who's
overweight
who who had to buy a lamborghini because
he needed to compensate so lamborghini
you're out and i'm so sorry to say that
now we're looking at the ford mustang
and we're looking the rolls-royce rave
i'll tell you real quick t.i one of my
favorite rappers alive has a great song
about rates i don't know if you've ever
heard it it's [ __ ] awesome and i have
a dream about listening to that song in
a wraith in my own wraith and listening
to ti and then i bump into ti one time
i'm like i like your song wraith and
he's like oh yeah and i go yeah i got
the kryptos which one do you have and
he's like oh you got the kryptos i got
the kryptos and then we high five and
then we hug and he goes we should be
friends i go i always thought that i'm
getting the wraith i'm getting the
wraith i'm gonna be the old man in a
wraith
with
big sunglasses with gold sides i'm gonna
start wearing open shirts i might even
swing back and get the deep cut classic
tee
meets
[Music]
my mouth just watered jamon fuller
1425
this is an acorn fed free-range
all-natural no preservatives 15 to 17
pounds lives on a rack with the hoof
removed personally i like the hoof i
like to know what i'm eating i would
love to have one of these in my house
because it's it's a great it's just a
it's it's great for when people come
over you you haven't you put it out and
i don't think it needs to be
refrigerated i think you leave it out
all day long i spend a lot of time on
the road one of my favorite things in
the world is having people over but
having people over and creating a
beautiful spread whether it's
charcuterie whether it's just meats and
cheeses and and some some veggies you
find the cool [ __ ] you bring it home and
then when people come over you put it
out and you watch them kind of get their
mind blown and they're like whoa what is
this mustard let's see what's next okay
a5 wagoo state flight 799
three stakes
12 ounces
extremely rare
this is my [ __ ]
because i i'm all i'm about heart health
and i know that you're gonna be like
shut the [ __ ] up i go to my cardiologist
every six months the one thing i'm going
to tell you about
a5 wagyu is it is filled with omega-3 so
you cook it medium-rare and then that
felt fat that's in it is identical to
the fact it's in salmon this is one kobe
a5 a5 is the like that's the first
generation that's the [ __ ] you want
wagyu strips take 12 ounce kobe is like
the original one and these are all
different farms if i'm not mistaken
they're all different farms and i think
they're from japan and those farms in
japan they make our all our farms look
like pigsties they are so next level
they take such good care of this cattle
these are the stakes
that you pull out and you have with your
dad and a glass of wine and by the way
you don't each get a steak you do one
steak you do one steak and you take your
time with it what a great call man wagyu
[ __ ] let's see what's next okay beyond
meat fresh beef meat alternative for 181
dollars sounds tasty what's next venison
sampler now this is what i'm talking
about 129.99
right now joe rogan's heart just skipped
a beat he's like dude who killed it
[Laughter]
elk medallions elk is when done well elk
is phenomenal with elk you gotta reverse
sear it you gotta smoke it then take it
in put it in a little butter get your
pan really hot on both sides right
before the pandemic i do i literally it
starts and i go over to rogan's
place to do a podcast and he looks at me
this is like the beginning when everyone
cared about everyone you know and he was
like how are you on meat and i was like
uh i think we're good he goes come on
i'm taking the back and he gave me
50 pounds of
elk and venice just just of of just game
and he was like take this back to the
family make sure you have some food we
have the a5 wagyu steak flight at 799
dollars we have the venison sampler at
129.99 or we have the iberico
de bellota
jamon
full leg at 1425
if i am nothing i'm a man
who wants to live in great moments
i want to find the moment that sparkles
in your life i like to look in someone's
eyes when you offer them a drink i like
the look in your wife eyes when you give
her a kiss out of nowhere and she goes
oh what was that for
and the only one that's going to deliver
that is the iberico de belo tajamon full
leg every time i pull it out it's got to
be what john holmes felt like when you
pull it out and whip it out and put it
on the counter and everyone's like whoa
what is that you're like it's real touch
it all right here we go
adrenaline adventures
let's go on an adventure all right first
one cross tibetan bridge
in cavalier italy 21 this is right up my
alley a controlled danger it's a
suspension bridge originally opened in
2006 heights up from 300 feet on the
ground
nearly a third of a mile in length for
uh probably 12 years of my life i did
the craziest [ __ ] anyone could ever do
first person to jump off stratosphere in
las vegas swam with great white sharks i
was an mma fighter a bull fighter i was
a rodeo clown for a day i am an expert
in finding adventure and so i will tell
you right now this tibetan bridge
crossing in italy for 21 it's a great
price point but if you go a little
further north in interlaken there's a
rope swing
that will knock your dick in the dirt
hydro shark experience i've done this it
is hyper claustrophobic
145 for 15 minutes you are in a bullet
with a dude there's only a couple dudes
that own these like there's not these
aren't everywhere and he is trying to
break it he is trying to do stuff to
dive and when you go under it is not
like going under in a submarine which
i've done i've done a submarine dive in
uh hawaii you are die you're going under
like a dolphin just
water rushing over you it goes black for
a second and then you shoot up out of
the air i've done this i've actually
done this exact one rio secreto
cave tour
129. explore the natural booties of the
ancient cave immerse yourself in a
magical underworld and it is magical it
really is magical duration six hours is
that worth 129
[ __ ] yes do i take the virgin galactic
trip to space for 450 000
it's a spaceship and a mother ship
climbed together just below 50 000 feet
okay i've been to 47. when the pilot was
i was there the other day
when the pilot releases the spaceship
from the mothership the spaceship rocket
ignites sending the craft up into space
a little over mach 3.
the colors outside the window change
from blue
to indigo
to midnight black
as you reach space this is [ __ ]
amazing and you just sold me something i
didn't know i wanted when you're talking
about
like my buddy thompson girl only flies
private that's all he does he's very
wealthy and he just loves spending money
and he just only flies private make sure
to put that in the show
but you think about how much you spend
on private flights 450 000 you're never
gonna forget this flight it goes from
indigo to midnight to dark blue to
seeing a curvature to
holy [ __ ] and then
i want that moment for 450 000 i can get
that moment that's real
that's money well spent
we got one more oh shut the [ __ ] up
oh
let's take a look at some beers
here we go
oh sam adams utopia 10th anniversary
edition 1700
whoa
notes of vanilla plum
raisin and prune so if i'm uh charles
dickens i'll really love it oh mom all
the plums and raisins ready just the
prunes with a note of vanilla you know
sometimes with beer too far east is west
now look i love sam adams sam adams is a
beer for someone who likes beer and
doesn't want to get blitzed i like to
get blitzed okay let's see the next one
vesplatrin 12 for 3064.79
only sold by appointment at a monastery
in germany i am already leading to this
just the the folklore of this beer the
dream of this beer prices include round
trip plane ticket from los angeles to
brussels plus a train ticket from
brussels to the town of fleitrin 24
bottles of trappist vest vladren hints
of sweet dark caramel malt who doesn't
love that spice and fig i could pass on
the fig but i bet after 12 of them you
don't even notice the fig anymore snake
venom beer 62 dollars and 24 cents
for 12 ounces of the world's strongest
beer
67.5 abv one beer puts a dent in your
night frozen several times after
fermentation process the ice crystals
are then removed resulting in a higher
alcohol content there is no carbonation
i think i'm gonna pass i think you're
asking me to drink an ice cold dull
whiskey the liquid is too thick which is
what we all look for in a beer is thick
liquid that we have to suck through our
teeth all right next one rocky mountain
oyster stealth seven dollars 10 ounces
roasted barley seven special malts and
25 pounds of freshly sliced and roasted
bull testicles
i think you want
hints of bull testicles just like a hint
i feel like i should drink these within
six seconds and the clown can come in
and rip it out of my hand yeah yeah yeah
that's bull test goals
huh best flavor and abby without a doubt
it's the story it's the dream
it's the monastery it's a monk it's a
snow cap you're in a castle there's no
air conditioning that's it thank you for
coming on the gq shopping spree with me
check out all the other people did their
shopping sprees i've watched all of them
and they're better than this one i can
tell you that right now i'm bert criser
thank you for watching my shopping spree